since he first appeared on the big
screen in 1962 James Bond has become a
worldwide film sensation bond with 24
official James Bond adventures and three
unofficial films the franchise can be a
bit overwhelming especially if you're
new to the series some of these movies
remain classics today while others not
so much
let's take a look at every James Bond
film ever made and rank them from worst
to best chances are good this list will
leave you shaken and stirred Casino
Royale 1967 due to some
behind-the-scenes drama producer Charles
Feldman opted to make his version of
Casino Royale a satire casting comedic
actor Peter Sellers as one of many James
Bond's it gets complicated and Orson
Welles as the Sherif despite being a
spoof 1967's Casino Royale is more
cheesy and cringe inducing than actually
funny and can easily be skipped on your
next two bond-athon this is an historic
day in our saga sir James
the day Smosh finally eliminated the
original James Bond a view to a kill
1985 Roger Moore's final appearance as
James Bond in a view to a kill is by far
his weakest Mothe delivers a performance
that could be described as zombie light
dozing his way through nearly every
scene making matters worse the Plus is
nearly non-existent it centers on a
Silicon Valley magnate played by
Christopher Walken who wants to control
the market for computer chips and
although walking on his henchwoman
played by Grace Jones do a fine job of
what they were given their performances
couldn't redeem this movie so does
anybody else want to drop out the man
with the Golden Gun 1974 Roger Moore's
second outing as bond and the man with
the Golden Gun was also pretty shabby
the movie tries too hard to be flashy
and nearly everything overshadows Moore
himself the kung-fu scenes seem cheesy
and tacked on and there's a decided lack
of typical Bond spy gadget ray on the
plus side the movie does offer two of
the coolest bad guys of the series
Christopher Lee is Scaramanga
and Irv a village say as his henchmen
Knick Knack after Percy 1983 director
John Glenn resorted to a tired formula
for octopus a of all the Raj
more Bond films this one might just be
the cheesiest featuring jewelry heists a
cult and the well domination storyline
involving nuclear weapons Octopussy
suffers from an overabundance of plots
and an underwhelming lack of substance
and remember bonds ridiculous disguises
in the movie how could you forget Casino
Royale at 1954 James Bond might be a
movie icon but his first on-screen
appearance was actually on television in
1954 Casino Royale was produced as an
episode of the CBS anthology drama
called climax which was actually
performed and broadcast live starring
Barry Nelson as bond and Peter Lorre as
the Sharif the episode was mostly
faithful to the novel except that bond
is an American CIA agent instead of mi6
it's not a terrible take on the stories
per se but it doesn't have the
production value of its peers that said
it's still pretty impressive that they
pulled it off in front of a live
audience at all Tomorrow Never Dies 1997
Pierce Brosnan second outing as James
Bond was the same suave and smooth
double O agent would come to know in
Goldeneye and his on-screen chemistry
with Teri Hatcher steams up every scene
they share or so Jonathan Pryce presents
are much more realistic villain than
normal a media mogul who attempts to
start a war in order to boost his news
market share have some breaking news
however despite the shiny exterior and
the new arsenal of gadgets there's very
little new ground explored in Tomorrow
Never Dies and that plays a little too
safe to stand out in the series the
world is not enough 1999 Brosnan's bond
outings might have been good in terms of
his personality but there is still way
too much formula in play with the world
is not enough and while most of the
supporting cast was solid
including sophie marceau as Elektra King
and Robert Carlyle as Renaud
the overall acting of the pic took a
major hit with Denise Richards portrayal
of nuclear physicist Christmas Jones
died another day 2010 boy's final stint
as James Bond Pierce Brosnan gave his
best performance in the role since his
debut in gold and i-beam DC have with Mr
Bond
just surviving mr. Chang just surviving
perhaps he had the solid plot to think
well apart from that space laser bit the
film successfully evokes the feel of
classic Bond films with throwback
imagery like Halle Berry's jinx emerging
from the ocean and many of the action
sequences were actually exciting like
the fight between jinx and Miranda Frost
at the end of the film and fortunately a
diner the day's special effects do not
always hold up Live and Let Die 1973
this movie's main floors revolve around
the unimpressive main villain mr. big
and his plot to give away free heroin in
order to get a corner on the markets
despite this it's still an adequate
entry into the franchise and the Jane
Seymour as solitaire remains one of the
best Bond girls to date Quantum of
Solace Daniel Craig second outing is
James Bond as suffer some fundamental
flaws like the villain Dominic Greene
and his plot to monopolize Bolivia's
fresh water supplies that's a pretty
boring idea for an international caper
on the other hand it's also a pretty
dark film with a bond set on revenge and
not a tongue-in-cheek
weapons sight Olga Kurylenko is great as
a Bond girl and the inferno fight in the
final act is the stuff of nightmares
Spectre 2015 in this installment we
finally get to see our hero come face to
face with the Blofeld the leader of the
shadowy organization Spectre that might
have been exciting in and of itself but
at times the film's plot seems a little
contrived that
said the action and stunt sequences rose
to new heights without relying on
computer-generated imagery and Monica
Bellucci is delightful as a Bond girl so
it's still definitely worth your time
Moonraker 1979 this installment of the
Bond franchise features one of the most
unrealistic plots of all a spacecraft is
hijacked in order to release a deadly
chemical around the world and Roger
Moore's portrayal slips from merely
flippant to positively silly there's
still a lot to like about Moonraker
because the company is cheerful and the
cast does sell the silliness fans also
applauded the return of Jaws and the
romantic epilogue will still go down as
containing one of the best Bond double
entendre moments in history my god
what's punk doing
I think he's attempting reentry sir
diamonds are forever 1971 Sean Connery's
return to the Bond fold and diamonds are
forever didn't Sparkle quite as much as
its predecessors the seventies era of
Vegas scenery seems a little too garish
for bond and the movie ignores much of
the source material however there are a
few great chase scenes and the badass
bodyguards Bambi and thumper so there's
a lot to like about this pic - for your
eyes only 1981 director John Glenn
delivered a delightfully stripped-down
Bond film with for your eyes only it
approaches the feel of the earliest Bond
movies and more gives his most serious
and rugged performance yet the return to
a Cold War threat was a smart move as
was the decision to mix any large and
overly bombastic set pieces what remains
is an action-packed
and smiley shot movie that does have its
flaws but is definitely an enjoyable
Bond film nonetheless The Living
Daylights 1987 when Timothy Dalton
stepped into the role after more critics
seemed to miss his predecessors [ __ ]
penis and complained about him being too
uptight part of what helps keep James
Bond films entertaining is a sardonic
tongue-in-cheek wit displayed by Bond
himself nevertheless Dalton is backed up
by good supporting performances and the
plot isn't as outlandish as most
centering on the KGB and the tale of
defection and smuggling add in a few
good action scenes and the living
daylights redeems itself as a
better-than-average Bond film never say
never again 1983 even though the story
of never say never again is just another
version of
Thunderball there's something about this
movie that's more entertaining than the
original Max von Sydow delivers a
wonderful performance as Blofeld and a
Rowan Atkinson is nervously hilarious as
bonds handler at the British Consulate
it's comforting to see a more
experienced Sean Connery back in the
role he made famous but he's clearly
more comfortable and having more fun in
his final farewell to the Bond franchise
[Music]
The Spy Who Loved Me 1977 even though
it's not a great Bond film Roger Moore
started to hit his stride as the lead
character in his third attempt The Spy
Who Loved Me his on-screen chemistry
with arunya portrayed by Barbara Bach is
undeniable and the film opens with a
great stunt sequence while the main
villain and his dastardly plans the
world domination a rather lackluster The
Spy Who Loved me doesn't reduce
audiences to one of the all-time
greatest bond henchman Richard keels
jaws all in all it's a good entry in the
franchise and perhaps mores best outing
as James Bond license to kill 1989 in
Timothy Dodson second and final
performance as James Bond the filmmakers
opted to play to his strengths resulting
in a much darker and more violent Bond
film and while there are definitely a
few preposterous moments like a
capturing an airplane with a helicopter
on the whole license to kill is also
much more sensible than most Bond movies
like all good Bond films license to kill
us plenty of entertaining action scenes
and that this time is also in
entertaining plots that go along with
them remember you're only president for
life you only live twice 1967 even
though you only live twice as one of the
most improbable plots of all the Bond
films involving hijacked spacecraft it's
substantial charms are undeniable the
movie boasts some beautiful
cinematography so it's easy to forgive
the film's wandering script and
preposterous volcano hideouts and
countless one is very enjoyable on Her
Majesty's Secret Service 1969 in his
only appearance in the Bond circuit
George Lazenby is pretty wooden in his
delivery however those action sequences
paired with the tone and a tie Anna rigs
turn as Tracy made this one a keeper not
to mention the villain Blofeld is played
convincingly by Telly Savalas
under the emotional punch of the final
scene as a thoroughly enjoyable
installment to the Bond franchise
Goldeneye 1995 aka the best Bond film
app to reinvent the franchise Pierce
Brosnan took over the roles of pons and
managed to strike all the right notes
Goldeneye is a completely original story
that introduces Sean beans former mi6
agents Trevelyan as a primary villain
from the entertaining action sequences
to the extraordinary set pieces and
snowonder this movie made for such a rad
a video game
Thunderball 1965 as the fourth film in
the series Thunderball was perfectly
placed to capitalize on the height of
the Cold War with a plot focusing on two
stolen atomic bombs and the bonds
attempt to recover them from Spectre
while it isn't quite as good as its
three predecessors Thunderball is still
a very solid Bond movie with a
spectacular scenery and action sequences
and the while it could have used some
judicious editing it's still a visual
treat Skyfall 2012 for Skyfall the Bond
series took a leap away from
double-oh-seven to focus instead on the
past upon superior m and the former mi6
agent turned terrorist to Raoul Silva
played by Javier Bardem Skyfall hits all
the right notes for a classic Bond film
from the exotic locales to the
compelling plot full of twists and let's
not forget how Adele's sexy theme song
left people swooning four months after
this movie dropped doctor no 1962 the
very first James Bond film remains a
classic all the elements of later Bond
films were introduced here the stylistic
opening credits exotic locales the James
Bond theme and his trademark catchphrase
to name a few
it's an action-packed 109 minutes of
pure audience escapism Sean Connery is
suave and the natural in the world of
pun showing why he'd hold on to the par
for 7 different films only the lack of
an impressive henchman for dr. know and
some pacing issues prevent this movie
from topping our list the James Bond the
formula was suddenly established in dr.
now and was only improved upon in the
next two installments Casino Royale 2006
Daniel Craig's first turn as
double-oh-seven was meant to introduce a
complete reboot of the James Bond
franchise sets at the very start of a
secret agent career and it was so
successful that it breathed new life
into the series instead of treating Bond
as window dressing to go along with
jaw-dropping action scenes
the production team made the wise choice
to actually let bonds haunted and human
personality shine through in addition to
Craig's convincing performance and
evergreens complicated turn as Vesper
masse Nicholson plays a convincing and
creepy lush reef between the acting the
intense action sequences and the
emotional resonance of the movie but the
new Casino Royale is one of the best and
the James Bond series From Russia With
Love 1963 sure
Connery's second outing as bond is even
better than the first and From Russia
With Love is also bolstered by standout
action sequences like the fight scene
aboard the Orient Express which would
inspire numerous other train scenes and
later Bond films everything is more
colorful and there are several memorable
one-liners and funny visual gags that
make From Russia With Love an example of
bonds at his finest Goldfinger 1964
although the margin between the top four
Bond films as nearly razor thin
Goldfinger comes out on top from the
dramatic and shocking opening sequence
to amazing gadget Horry and the
unforgettable image of Shirley Eaton
painted gold from head-to-toe
Goldfinger is a movie that continues to
impress you'd be hard-pressed to find a
better henchman than odd-job and the
name of Bond girl [ __ ] Galore still
inspires a giggle today the laser table
and the climatic fight in the airplane
are among the best Bond scenes of all
time and Goldfinger was also the first
Bond movie to include the line shaken
not stirred many other Bond films
imitated the formula perfected in
Goldfinger but few come close for you
bond James Bond thanks for watching
click the loop icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel plus check out all this
cool stuff we know you'll love to
[Applause]
[Music]